in this video I'd like to give you a few
tips on how to behave on confidence
cards so that it is both effective and
also respect for it with the other
members on the coin I trust this is
going to be especially relevant in these
times where we know they're just so much
more conference chords going on than
usually hi guys my name is hi and
related welcome to another coffee break
with firm learning today I'm talking
about conference calls and as probably
you know in consulting conference cards
are so common you probably on a usual
day have more than five conference calls
going on since about half year ago I
made them from consulting moving into
industry and now I'm working for a large
German retailer
so I joined in the end of 2019 and at
that time our company it was quite
unusual to do conference calls it was a
very much more classically conservative
culture of people rather preferring to
either just call somebody up or just
meet in person in order to discuss
things where for obvious reasons this
changed due to the global pandemic that
is going on and also here Germany in a
substantial way since several weeks now
a large proportion of our leadership
team is in home office and I work from
home offices where you currently see me
filming this sitting in my home office
in Munich and this brought quite a
significant change in culture in our
organization as now we have daily
conference calls every morning for
instance there's a conference called
check-in with the senior leadership team
of our company and both in this retail
company I'm currently working with but
also in consulting I've been working
with several clients I have observed a
whole number of habits that people have
on conference calls which are just
either disturbing for the majority of
the people or just plain ineffective for
the objective of the conference call
namely having a good and to-the-point
discussion of the topics at hand that
just need to be solved by the team that
is now just talking together so in this
video I like to give you five tips on
what you can do in order to make your
conference cards more
effective less of an annoyance to all
the people on there and if you find this
useful feel free to forward this video
to some of your co-workers as well so
that your conference call experience
hopefully improves for your whole
organization so first thing this might
seem to be one of the more obvious
things go on mute it is incredible to me
that most people who are dying in a
conference call are not on mute and just
have the microphone on the whole time
even though they are not talking and
this is irritating and disturbing for
some obvious reasons even though it
might be quiet where you sit at the
moment right now it can always happen
that an ambulance passes by your street
or there are some other sudden noises
that suddenly come up that then disturb
the whole coil and even if they're not
some hidden sudden loud noises just you
sitting in front of your computer
pressing buttons on your keyboard may be
eating something maybe your neighbors
saying something in a loud way all of
these are things which are disturbing
which create a constant level of
background noise which is just not
helpful when you want to have a good
discussion in your conference card so my
first advice is whenever you do not talk
go on mute this is the absolute minimum
that you need to do in order to be
respectful to your other co-workers go
on mute and unmute yourself just
whatever you really need to say
something and if you don't need to say
something
go on you to not let other people be
stirred by the background noises that
you will have while being on the
microphone now the second tip and this
is something that I think we all know is
where and to what extent this issue
exists also depends on the conference
call system that you are using but then
we frequently you hear in the background
these automated voices of the conference
call system saying something like Peter
Droid to call Peter Rowe the coil Peter
join to call Peter Bob the caller right
so whenever somebody joins or drops the
call in many conference call systems
there's an automatic voice saying that
to all the people in the car and of
course if you've been there if you've
seen these kind of things
this is extremely disturbing because if
somebody joins or drops the call
basically the conversation is
interrupted by their voice so how can
you diminish this disturbance as much as
possible when and again this very much
also depends on the conference call
system that you're using how exactly
that works but frequently whenever you
dial into a conference call the system
often asks you for your name so it will
say something like please tell us your
name after the beep sound and then press
the hash button right so it asks you to
say your name and then press the button
usually the hash key so that the system
knows that now the recording can stop
your name so what you need to do where
the little trick is that when you're
being asked to tell your name just don't
tell your name just don't say anything
and directly press the hash key so it
asks you and you directly press it
without any second left so that it
cannot really record anything and then
when you join or when you drop the call
there will just be no sound of the
system saying your name for everybody
because this recording of the name just
that exists so whenever the system asks
you for your name press the hash key
don't say your name and you will be fine
of course if there's a strict rule in
your company that you need to say your
name well then do that don't get a
trouble for that but most companies
there isn't anything like that and I can
tell you if you do this and if you tell
or your co-workers to do this your
conference calls will go much more
smoothly because this kind of
disturbance just isn't there anymore so
guys my third tip is about what to do
when you actually join the conference
call late and of course this can happen
for all kinds of reasons but what many
people do which I find quite
disrespectful and disturbing is the
person's late the discussion is already
ongoing
and then the person joins to call and
then just says something like hi guys hi
yeah I'm late sorry for that I was just
stuck in traffic but now I'm here sorry
for that right and by doing that he
disrupts he interrupts the whole
conversation and just stops the person
who is currently doing and especially a
large conference calls where there many
people online in the car and many people
come in late with all these people then
apologize for being late and then in the
worst case even also different reason
why they were late this is just such a
disturbance so from my experience the
best practice radius if you are joining
the conference call and you are late
just say nothing don't introduce
yourself that you are there now don't
apologize why you are late just say
nothing and this is especially true if
you can hear that the car already
started and there's already a
conversation going on and of course that
might be different if you are the CEO of
the company or you are the person is
actually supposed to lead the whole
conference call is the most important
person in the coil then maybe it's okay
and then it may make sense that you let
all the others know that you are there
but if you are just one of many
participants most likely the others
really not really care if you are there
or not or at least they won't care as
much for you to interrupt the whole
discussion just for letting in the know
so just be quiet and just use the next
opportunity where you see a moment when
you can just add something meaningful to
the discussion but you can say that and
then also by doing the letting let us
know that now you join the chorus may
the fourth tip on conference cards is to
be concise so for all these reasons and
many others conference cards can be
quite tiresome and annoying everybody
should contribute for making these cards
as short and as efficient as possible
and we all know these people who just in
meetings and conversations need to have
the stage time these people that feel
like that they always need to say
something that even though that has been
already said many times they need to
repeat
again people that state the obvious just
to say something this is annoying and
this is not only annoying conference
calls but of course also in regular
meetings as well but this is especially
annoying conference cards because
conference cards in itself often our a
bit of an annoying situation and this
only makes it worse so make sure that
when you say something it really adds
venue to the conversation
you're not just repeating things that
others have already said you are not
stating the obvious so things that are
completely obvious but you just say them
just because you feel like need to say
something do not do these things beep on
sighs for the sake of everybody involved
and now my fifth tip is if any how
possible only join the call if you have
a more or less stable connection I mean
also we've all been in these situations
where are people joined from an airport
maybe already sitting in an airplane or
they join from the car or they join from
the train and then they constantly lose
the connection drop off the car then
drop in again and this is just the
disturbance because even if you do not
say your name at the beginning so it
doesn't always say Peter joined or left
the call often does that these the
beeping sound which is the disturbance
so if you already know that you will not
have a stable connection for your
telephone conference and if there's any
way for you that maybe your attendance
isn't absolutely crucial or maybe
there's a way to postpone into a moment
may actually have a more stable
connection do not join if your
connection is unstable because again it
is a big disturbance to all the other
people on the call it is annoying and
it's a waste of time so be respectful to
the time of your co-workers so these
were my five tips and of course I'm
interested not to hear how is your work
environment changing these dire times in
this global pandemic is it true for you
as well
that you're not having many more
conference calls let me know what your
experience is below in the comments I'd
love to hear from you
and if you have any other tips that
you'd like to share with our community
here on firm learning let us know I'm
sure that others would appreciate as
well
what are your do's and don'ts for having
good and effective telephone conferences
and of course if you took any value out
of this video at all if always please
press the like button to help the
YouTube algorithm that other people find
this video as well and if you'd like to
see more videos on how you can be
successful in the first years of your
career videos similar like this please
press the subscribe button of course
I'd also love to hear your feedback
topics you'd like to see covered in this
channel just let me know and I include
this on my list of ideas for the future
videos I will release at least one video
every week so thank you for hanging in
here with me thank you for joining thank
you for watching my name is Haile from
firm learning stay safe everybody and
have a good day